[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الا تفهمونه نحن لم نستهدف بوتين ولماذا
لا تكون هذه خطه روسيه نكره الهدف منها
محو اوكرانيا هكذا صرخ الزلنسكي وبوتين
يظهر ملوحا بيديه انا مازلت على قيد
الحياه والاستخبارات الامريكيه تسرب فيديو
يكشفهيه الطرف الذي كان يريد اغتيال بوتين
فيما الاستخبارات الروسيه تعثر على مسيرات
جديده
[موسيقى]
هجومه المضاد لاستعاده ما سقط في يد الجيش
الروسي ووزير الدفاع الروسي يدعو الى
مضاعفه عجله الانتاج للسلاح الروسي
والرئيس الايراني يلتقي ببشار الاسد في
سوريا فهل ذهب من اجل السعوديه وتركيا
والاطراف السودانيه المتنازعه تتفق
والفصائل الفلسطينيه ترد وصافرات الانذار
تدوي في تل وامريكا تمد يدها لتصافح الصين
الانتقام الروسي تتسارع الاحداث والزمن
يفقد دواسه الفرامل مع تصاعد الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه واقتراض قوات موسكو من
السيطره على باخموت بالكامل ومحاوله
اغتيال بوتين هنا تختلط الاوراق مجددا
وتتكشف الحقيقه فبعد ان اعلنت قوات الدفاع
الجوي والاستخبارات الروسيه تعطيل طائرتين
مسيرتين حاولتا الهجوم على قصر الكرمبن
وسط موسكو ومن الطبيعي هنا ان تتهم موسكو
كييف بالتخطيط الاغتيال الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين فالامر لا يستحق الذكاء
ولا الداعي من استدعاء المحقق كونان هنا
يؤكد ان الرئيس الروسي لم يصب باي اذى
جراء الهجوم الاوكراني واصفا للهجوم
بالعمل الارهابي وقالت موسكو انها تحتفظ
بحق الرد على الهجوم في المكان والزمان
المناسبين وذكرت الرئاسات الروسيه ان
بوتين لم يكن في مبنى الكرملين اثناء
الهجوم بالمسيرتين اذ كان يمارس مهامه
بمقر اقامته في منطقه نوفو اوغاري يوفو
قرب موسكو ونشرت صورا له وهو بخير اذا فمن
الذي نفذ الهجوم ومن اين تم اطلاق
المسيرات الهجوم نفذ بواسطه مسيرات تجاريه
اطلقت من مسافه غير بعيده من شارع مخوفيال
القريب من الكرملين حسب محللين عسكريين
ممنشر فيديو غريب قبل هجوم المسيرات على
يظهر فيه رجلان على قبه المبنى لحظه
انفجار المسيرات وسائل اعلام قالت بانه تم
العثور على مسيره ثالثه في ضواحي موسكو
والعمل جار على تفكيك شحنته الناسفه قبل
قليل اعلنت وزاره الطوارئ عن العثور على
مسيره ايضا هنا في ضواحي
طبعا هذه المسيره الان يجري
تفكيك العضو الناسفه التي
موجوده معها حسنا حسنا موسكو اتهمت
بالوقوف وراء الهجوم فما هو راي الاوكران
اوكرانيا نفت صلتها بالهجوم اذ قالت
سكرتيره لجنه الخارجيه في البرلمان
الاوكراني سولونيا بوبروغوسكا انه لا صله
لبلاديا بالهجوم على الكرملين رجحت
المسؤوله الاوكرانيه ان تكون السلطات
الروسيه دبرت الهجوم لتبرير تكليف هجماتها
على اوكرانيا وفق تعبيرها مما صرح مسؤول
رفيع في الرئاسه الاوكرانيه بان الهجوم
على الكرملين لا يحقق لك شيئا ولا يغير
الموقف في ارض المعركه فمن الذي نفذه اذا
ايعقل ان تكون روسيا نفسها الرد الروسي
جاء على لسان نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
الذي ادعى الى تصفيه
الاوكرانيسكي واعضاء حكومه قائلا بعد
الاعتداء الارهابي اليوم لم يبقى خيار
امام روسيا سوى تصفيه
جسديا مع اعضاء حكومته لسنا بحاجه لبقاء
زلنسكي على قيد الحياه لاعلان الاستسلام
غير المشروط دائما هناك بديل وفي وقت سابق
قال النائب في مجلس الدوم الروسي فيكتور
سوبوليف انه قد حان الوقت لاطلاق هجوم
صاروخي على مقر اقامه الرئيس الاوكراني
كما طالب رئيس مجلس الدوم الروسي
باستخدام الاسلحه القادره على ردع النظام
في كييف وتدميره واضاف في بيان روسيا يجب
الا تتفاوض مع الرئيس الاوكراني
بعد الهجوم الذي نفت كييف مسؤوليتها عنه
جهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي كان قد اعلن
في وقت السابقين احباط مخطط للاستخبارات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه لاغتيال عدد من قاده
القرم واكد الامن الفيدرالي الروسي ان من
بين المخطط لاستهدافهم رئيس القرم مشيرا
الى انه تم احتجاز سبعه من المشتبه فيهم
بالتخطيط لتنفيذ هجمات في القرن والتجسس
على مسؤولين فيها روسيا تتوعد السلطات
الاوكرانيه باتخاذ اجراءات انتقاميه ردا
على محاوله كييف اغتيال بوتين فكيف سيرد
بوتين على هذه الخطوه الجريئه تداعيات
الهجوم على الكريملين لن تكون محصوره على
اوكرانيا بل ستشمل كل اعداء روسيا وذلك ما
دفع البيت الابيض للتصريح بان واشنطن لا
تشجع اي هجمات اوكرانيه خارج الحدود مضيفا
لا يمكننا تاكيد صحه اتهام روسيا لكييف
بشن هجوم على الكرملين وقالت الناطقه باسم
البيت
ان الولايات المتحده ليست في وضع يسمح لها
بتاكيد تفاصيل التصريحات عن الهجمات على
وكان وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
اشار في وقت سابق الا انه لا يستطيع اثبات
صحه اتهام روسيا بان اوكرانيا حاولت
اغتيال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين في
هجوم بطائره مسيره لكنه قال انه سينظر
بعين الريبه لاي شيء يصدر عن الكرملين
وجدد بلنك التقاط واشنطن بقدره كييف على
استعاده اراضيها معتبرا ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا فشلوا استراتيجي لروسيا على حد
تعبيره وبالعوده الى المعارك على الارض
صرح مالك شركه فاقلار انه يعتقد انه هجوم
اوكرانيا المضاد بدا بالفعل ليؤكد لنا
وزير الدفاع الروسي ذلك بعد ان دعى الى
مضاعفته انتاج بلاده من الصواريخ والاسلحه
عاليه في اسرع وقت ممكن واضاف ان القوات
الروسيه تواصل تدمير الاسلحه التي قدمها
الغرب لاوكرانيا مشيرا الى ان خسائر
القوات الاوكرانيه خلال الشهر الماضي
تجاوزت 15 الف شخص فيما تستمر القوات
الروسيه في مهاجمه قواعد الجيش الاوكراني
فيرسون وتكمل تطبيق مدينه اما قوات فانها
تؤكد السيطره على تماما والجيش الاوكراني
ينفي ذلك وفي ظل الصراعات الدوليه
المستمره بين الدول الكبرى والضغوط
القائمه وجدت جنوب افريقيا نفسها امام
مازق استقبال الرئيس الروسي على اراضيها
مطلع الشهر المقبل وذلك بسبب قرار صادر
بحقه من المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه مما
يترتب عليه اعتقاله فهل يجرؤ احد على
اعتقال الدب الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
الاحداث والتطورات في حادث هو ثاني خلال
اسبوع احتجزت ايران ناقله نفط ترفع على
مبنما في مضيق هرمز كما اعلنت البحريه
الامريكيه وهو ما اكدته وكاله تسنيم
الايرانيه الرسميه لكنها لفتت الى ان
القوات البحريه التابعه للحرس الثوري
الايراني احتجزت ناقله نفط اجنبيه مخالفه
في مياه مضيق هرمز وكانت البحريه
الامريكيه اعلنت قبل ايام ان ايران احتجزت
ناقله نفط ترفع علم الجزر مارشال في خليج
عمان قالت وزاره خارجيه جنوب السودان من
الرئيس الباكر اتصالا هاتفيا مع قائد
الجيش السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد
قوات الدعم السريعه محمد حمدان وفق خلاله
البرهان وحميدتي على هدنه لمده سبعه ايام
بدايه من يوم الخميس الرابع من مايو ايار
الجاري واضافت الخارجيه ان البرهان
وحميدسي وفق
على ارسال ممثلين لهما الى احدى عواصم
الدول الافريقيه لبدء محادثه سلام اعلنت
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه مقتل فلسطيني
واصابه خمسه اخرين في الغارات الاسرائيليه
التي استهدفت قطاع غزه هذا وتسود حاله من
الهدوء الحذر غزه مع دخول اتفاق وقف اطلاق
النار بين الفصائل الفلسطينيه في القطاع
واسرائيل حيز التنفيذ بما اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي العوده الى الحاله الطبيعيه في
الجبهه الداخليه وكان سلاح الجو
الاسرائيلي قد اعلن شن غارات على قطاع غزه
وذلك ردا على عمليات اطلاق صواريخ من غزه
باتجاه زيروت والمستوطنات الاسرائيليه مما
ادى الى اصابه اسرائيلي بجروح خطيره قال
السفير الامريكي في بكين انه واشنطن تريد
قنوات التواصل افضل مع صينيين مضيفا ان
الولايات المتحده على استعداد لاجراء
مفاوضات مع الصين وبان واش تريد خلق اجواء
من الاستقرار في العلاقات مع الصين في
زياره هي الاولى من نوعها منذ اكثر من 12
عاما اجر الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيس
محادثات في دمشق مع نظيره السوري بشار
الاسد الذي اكد خلال اللقاء ثبات العلاقات
السوريه الايرانيه واستقرارها الزياره
التي تستغرق يومين يرافق رئيسي فيها وفد
وزاري سياسي واقتصادي رفيع وتضمنت الزياره
توقيع مذكره تفاهم للتعاون الاستراتيجي
الشامل بين البلدين
[موسيقى]